perfection
one tacular
see what happens next
headlines with those trademark phrases
for media startup Upworthy have been
inundating people's social media feed
since its founding in 2012.
Upworthy was started in New York a Nexus
for news and media companies Founders
Peter keckley and Eli Pariser built it
with a mission get people to share
socially charged stories that they
otherwise wouldn't New York is a place
of very opinionated to people and when
we started up worthy we really wanted to
start something that wasn't kind of
newly mouthed on the one hand on the
other hand we wanted to be a site that
wore our heart on our sleeve and this is
a great place obviously to to do that
and filled with people who are doing
that the site encourages users to repost
and share stories on topics ranging from
climate change to gun laws by adding
quirky headlines and compelling pictures
if you could make it accessible and
compelling rather than make people
suffer to learn about something that's
important maybe you could actually reach
that large audience those Cliffhanger
headlines are part of the secret sauce
that drives 40 to 50 million visitors to
the site each month with nearly
two-thirds of those views coming from
smartphones it's made up-worthy the 11th
most popular site on mobile the other
ingredient to making those posts go
viral is the story selection of Upworthy
70 content creators most media sites try
to throw as much as they can at the wall
and hope that some of it sticks we spend
all that time watching things and saying
nope wasn't good enough nope it wasn't
good enough you know a thousand times a
day it's on us all of us to stop sexual
assault Upworthy like many of its
competitors makes money by creating
sponsored content these posts are paid
for by businesses who want to use an
editorial platform to reach Their
audience companies are increasingly
finding that they need to connect with a
sense of purpose and that consumers
especially younger consumers want to
know what the brands that they're buying
from actually stand for and so Upworthy
is a great way for Brands to tell that
story